voici en bourse une petite ville de la
saskatchewan qui bat au rythme de son
équipe de hockey
les broncos il ya un nom une tragédie
routière décimée cette équipe dans les
jours qui ont suivi c'est ici à l'aréna
elle girl pietersen que la communauté
s'est réuni douze mois plus tard elle se
réunira encore une fois ce week-end
on vous en parlera dans un instant mais
tout d'abord voici un résumé des
événements qui nous ont menés jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
yann et 2018 devait en être une belle
pour les plans cause de hand ball pour
la première fois en cinq ans la
formation se taille une place en demi
finale des séries éliminatoires de la
ligue de hockey junior de la
saskatchewan le vendredi 6 avril et qui
fait en route vers ni par win pour le
cinquième match de la série
mais en quelques instants le sort
bascule l'autocar n'arrivera jamais à
destination
juste avant 17 heures un camion
semi-remorque ignore le panneau d'arrêt
à l'intersection des autoroutes 35 et
la collision est inévitable l'autocar
frappe le camion de plein fouet
l'impact est brutale une véritable
explosion et 29 personnes à bord 14
morts sur les lieux
deux autres vont succomber à leurs
blessures plus tard à l'hôpital
en beauce le drame bouleverse la
communauté l'aide aux victimes et à
leurs familles s'organisent rapidement
le dimanche 8 avril
ils sont des milliers à se réunir à
l'aréna pietersen en recherche de
réconfort quelques jours plus tard des
canadiens d'un bout à l'autre du pays
peuvent être des chandails de hockey
pour montrer leur soutien
la vague de solidarité dépasse
rapidement les frontières du pays
bientôt des bâtons de raquer
apparaissent devant les portes de
maisons un peu partout dans le monde
le mot-clé botchkov devient un véritable
cri de ralliement
une campagne de sociaux financement a
pour objectif d'amasser 10 mille dollars
pour venir en aide aux familles ce
montant atteindra finalement 15,2
millions de dollars le 6 avril 2018 la
vie de votre famille a changé à jamais
et mois qui ont suivi fut remarqué par
le deuil la souffrance mais aussi
empreint d'espoir et de triomphe ce soir
du vous présentons certaines de ses
histoires dans boat
nous sommes un an après la tragédie
[Musique]
et voilà on vient de voir le visage des
seize personnes qui ont péri dans
l'accident
ce week-end la communauté se rassemblera
une fois de plus l aréna agger pietersen
pour le rendre hommage mais aussi rendre
hommage aux 13 survivants de cet
accident
ils ont dû passer à travers de
nombreuses épreuves cette année chacun
d'entre eux a sa propre histoire et
c'est là qu'on rejoint ma collègue omar
à isla lourmarin vous avez parlé avec la
famille d'un des survivants xhavit label
vous êtes entretenu avec le frère de
xavier isaac label qui est aussi joueur
de hockey
voilà exactement et qui aujourd'hui
avait vraiment un message de résilience
isaac
vous êtes le frère de sa vie la belle
qui était dans l'accident des crocos
l'an dernier commente arriver
aujourd'hui comment est-ce qu'il va ça
va bien maintenant à leur événement qui
est arrivé à morte l'année dernière très
tragique et on était très triste pour
tous les gens qui ont perdu l'envié
pour léa survivants on est content qu on
peut avoir les avoir comme postulat vie
épreuve d'avion on est on est très
content et il va aux fusions comme
jacques être trois fois par jour par
semaine et on est content pour avoir lui
dans notre vie comment ça a été la
dernière à nis pour vous le frère et
toute la famille s'était dit pcl
quelques temps mais
parce qu'il est la survie cet événement
est très content et va être le premier
anniversaire de cet événement qu'est ce
que ça représente pour vous ça
représente un événement de notre vie qui
est difficile trajets qu on va à ces
deux mêmes heures chaque personne qui
ont perdu la vie et de célébrer les
personnes qui vont avoir le reste de
leur vie
à l'avant on sent vraiment à votre votre
résilience votre force d'aller en avant
vous remet aussi aviez d'où est-ce que
vous puisez cette force inspiration pour
toute notre famille et il l'a beaucoup
de courage à faire ce qu'il fait chaque
jour c'est ça peut être difficile
quelques jours est plus facile les
autres mais toujours courageux y est ce
que vous avez un message aujourd'hui
pour les familles ou les gens qui nous
écoutent
on pense à tous des familles chaque jour
et à chaque personne et c'est un soutien
nouveau famille pour tous les patients
tous les familles des morts des ans leur
donne notre sport et merci beaucoup
disaient non c'est et on verra il y
avait aussi les parents de gilad elle
qui avait un message à livrer
aujourd'hui voilà et ça a été vraiment
un message axé sur l'espoir
[Musique]
et on verra parlant des parents bon vous
avez suivi cette histoire depuis ses
tout débuts en avril dernier vous avez
été présente à chacune des grandes
étapes à chacun des développements moi
vous avez été des premiers témoins en
fait d émotion extrême vécue par ses
parents oui absolument ces cas de le
dire
émotion extrême parce que dans le fond
c'est une tragédie d'une si grande
ampleur qu'elle est quasiment indicible
indescriptible 16 morts 13 blessés on
parle de parents de mère de famille deux
pères de familles qui ont perdu des fils
pour la plupart et au cours de la
dernière année là on a entendu des
témoignages absolument bouleversant des
familles qui parle d'anxiété de
dépression de la difficulté d'avancer
mais on a aussi entendu des familles
dire eh bien à travers la résilience que
c'est le moment de passer à autre chose
et de pardonner
et ça c'était le pass ça c'était le
pasteur de l'équipe des broncos qui
évidemment parler là de l'espoir et
surtout du pardo merci au maire est
aussi bon on parle au maire anne suivi
cette histoire depuis ses tout débuts
mais évidemment le pays en entier suit
cette histoire est aussi la communauté à
une bonne parce qu'il existe un lien
très étroit entre la communauté et son
équipe du rac et mes collègues charles
allende et hanane mohammad
on parle en fait un ici en fait de cette
symbiose qui existe à tous les matchs
locaux
c'est palpable mais jouer en double en
cause un bond sont galvanisés à
l'énergie dont pâtissent
cette saison c'est environ un citoyen
sur cinq s'est déplacé pour les matches
à domicile de l'équipe
natif de hambourg wigan poncelet a joué
tout son hockey mineur avec le problème
des broncos
il est le parfait exemple de cette
symbiose entre l'équipe des juniors et
les partitions de cette ville des
prairies ses coéquipiers et lui se font
un devoir de redonner aux gens qui
encouragent l'équipe reconnaissant
envers l'amour la fidélité des partisans
il n'y parlera en carembault l'amour et
la passion pour les blancs qu on soit
une histoire de famille génération en
génération
très jeune elle accompagnait son père
qui était juge de but lors des matchs et
blanc cause c'est d'ailleurs dans cet
aréna qui l'a rendu l'âme
[Applaudissements]
quatre des joueurs du bo longue pause
hébergé par sa famille l'ont grandement
aidé à travers ce sont dès aujourd'hui
dans ce même aréna et les six trous
premiers coups de patin ses fils et à
leurs premières lueurs d'espoir et
devenir un jour et blanco
et charles dont on parle de 23 ans bolt
ils étaient bloqués mais existe aussi un
lien 3 travers une autre communauté
celle du à qui bien évidemment est
spécialement à travers les ancien joueur
des broncos la tragédie les a vraiment
ébranlé très personnellement oui j'ai
parlé des anciens joueurs québécois qui
ont déjà joué à hamburg et l'un d'eux si
mon ado n'a joué qu'une seule saison en
beauté la saison 2003 2004
mais il a tout de même développé un fort
sentiment d'appartenance envers l'équipe
et la communauté
on peut écouter dans l'extrait suivant à
quel point il était ébranlée lors de la
tragédie du 6 avril 2018 si ça fait
quand même quelques années ne fait 15
ans que je joue en bo1 je pensais pas
que ça allait me toucher aux taxes au et
charles poncet s'est exemplifie en plus
qu'on a entendues au cours de la nuit
une intrusion qui revient souvent un bon
coach un jour broncos toujours ou en
effet simon nadeau cette année l'avait
eu la chance de partager le vestiaire
avec trois autres joueurs québécois dont
alex gagnon qui avait d'ailleurs été
nommé gardien de but de l'année dans la
ligue de hockey junior de la
saskatchewan et après cette fameuse
saison alex gagnon avec garder contact
avec son entraîneur chef bob berry mais
les aléas de la vie ont fait en sorte
qu'ils se sont perdus de vue
mais ça c'était avant que j'organise des
retrouvailles téléphonique entre les
deux hommes un vieux doit y ait eu à
tous via deux symboles than us back
baguenauder
[Rires]
merci beaucoup charles de là nous avons
parlé de ce lien étroit qui existe entre
les joueur des broncos est resté d'une
autre après la pause on va parler de ce
qui a changé depuis la tragédie est
aussi le père de la plus jeune victime
de cette tragédie à la mi-août nous
parle de la fondation qu'il a créé au
nom son fils
[Musique]
m
d'ailleurs ce dimanche a été procureur
proclamé journée du chandail vert en
l'honneur de logan boulet l'idée est
d'encourager les gens à avoir une
conversation autour du don d'organes et
c'est une des nombreuses choses qui a
changé en fait depuis l'accident mais il
ya aussi tout ce qui est question de
sécurité routière tant au niveau des
règles de camionnage que de sécurité
routière à bord des autocars et je
rejoins ma collègue emmanuelle poisson
pour en parler
emmanuel le gouvernement à changer ses
règles en fait depuis cet accident
oui en fait depuis l'accident plusieurs
gouvernements provinciaux ont fait face
à une question pressante
est ce que la formation pour les
camionneurs est suffisante pour prévenir
une autre tragédie comme celle des
broncos de rands bolt est bien plusieurs
enseignants la conclusion que non c'est
d'ailleurs le cas de la saskatchewan
mais aussi du manitoba et de l'alberta
qui exige désormais plus de 120 heures
de formation obligatoire pour les
nouveaux camionneurs l'alberta la
saskatchewan disque s'était penché sur
cette question avant même que la
tragédie ne se produise cependant il ya
des experts du milieu qui estime que
c'est vraiment cet événement du 6 avril
2018 qui a incité les gouvernements de
thé ces changements mais manuel malgré
ces changements dans quelques provinces
un problème subsiste toujours ce qu'il
ya un camionneur peut passer à travers
le pays est passé à travers des
provinces qui ont des règles différentes
en fait oui effectivement c'est le cas
au nouveau brunswick en nouvelle écosse
et à l'île du prince edouard ainsi qu'à
terre neuve et labrador et comme vous
l'avez dit père lui que c'est
effectivement vrai les camionneurs de
partout au pays peuvent effectuer des
trajets interprovince you avec ou sans
formation
mais ça devrait bientôt changer étant
donné que ottawa en 2020 il mettra en
place des normes nationales pour la
formation des camionneurs c'était une
mesure qui avait été recommandé dans le
rapport du canada saskatchewan et qui
avait été demandée par plusieurs proches
et familles et membres des familles des
victimes de la tragédie des broncos de
rands bolt est d'ailleurs en 2020
si on parle d'autres car il ya des
règles aussi qu'ils vont changer en
matière de ceinture de sécurité pour les
autocars de moyenne et de grande taille
oui ces autres cars devront être munis
de ceintures de sécurité à compter du
1er septembre 2020 transports canada dit
que cette mesure n'était à l'étude
depuis 2017 et mais n'a pas précisé si
cette mesure a été c'est le processus de
cette mesure a été accéléré en raison de
la tragédie des broncos de rambo est en
fait c'était également une mesure qui
avait été recommandé dans le rapport du
coroner de la saskatchewan et ainsi que
par des membres de la famille des
familles des victimes et de leurs
proches
merci manuel et on en parle la tragédie
a servi de catalyseur pour le don
d'organes pour changer les règles de
sécurité routière et l'héritage des
victimes de cet accident qui ont péri et
pas près de s'éteindre en fait une
fondation a été créée au nom de la plus
jeune victime de cet accident
la fondation a damé road legacy of des
bourses d'études et aussi des camps de
hacker et de liberchies aps
j'en ai parlé avec le père de adam la
soirée rock indie que l'idée derrière ça
est assez simple c'est une question de
donner au suivant
me dise pour commencer il dit moi qu'est
ce que vous tentez d'accomplir avec les
tient de raki et de leadership
nous essayons de transmettre aux enfants
des compétences de haut niveau les
outils dont ils ont besoin pour chasser
un niveau supérieur les habiletés
sportives sont bien sûr très importante
mais en même temps nous voulons aussi
développer des leaders qui ont un esprit
communautaire comme adam
nous voulons les encourager à devenir de
meilleures personnes de meyer membre de
la société d'alors pipe ournac mais
pourquoi c'était important pour vous de
mettre cette fondation sûre qui s'était
en partie pour redonner aux gens qui
nous ont aidés c'est aussi une façon de
garder l'héritage dadame bien vivant il
était le genre de personne qui aurait
redonné au suivant
il le faisait déjà mais s'il y en avait
eu la chance je crois qu'il aurait fait
beaucoup des choses que nous tentons
maintenant d'accueillir nous tentons de
transmettre son esprit de rendre la
communauté meilleur mais qui nous lisent
belle vous dites c'est qu'est ce que
vous pensez qu admirer en voyant qu'une
fondation porte son nom je pense
j'espère qu'il serait fier de ce que
nous tentons d'accomplir en ce moment
c'était le genre de personne qu'il était
il voulait aider donc je crois qu'il
serait heureux et web et explique qu'il
est difficile de s'imaginer à quel point
la dernière année a pu être difficile
pour vous ce qu'il fait de voir des
gestes positifs fait au nom d' adam vous
aident à travers cette épreuve
oui vraiment lorsqu'on va au camp de
hockey
on reçoit les commentaires positifs tu
es jeune ils nous disent que c'est un
honneur pour eux de participer et qu'ils
ont hâte de devenir des leaders à leur
façon de devenir de meilleures personnes
ça fait du bien à entendre
nous recevons aussi des commentaires
positifs de la part des parents il nous
parle de commencer quand les ont aidés
et des impacts positifs que nous avons
sur leurs enfants ils deviennent des
membres de la communauté qui ont un
souci d'aider les autres et pour en
savoir plus sur cette fondation vous
pouvez vous diriger sur le site web
convoi au bas de l'écran est resté des
nôtres après la pause on discutera de
l'incroyable périple des survivants de
la tragédie
[Musique]
samedi pour la prochaine livraison
l'impact des changements climatiques sur
la disponibilité des aliments et le riz
sauvage ingres est prisé des premières
nations
l'épicerie samedi 17h30 ici rdi
nous accueillons des étudiants qui
viennent de partout sur la planète
certains d'ailleurs ont tout un choc en
arrivant canada où les questions
d'identité sexuelle se discute
ouvertement second regard ce soir 21h30
is ir dit ok ça prend un lieu de réunion
de concret pompon pas cher pour plaire à
nos passés à nice et à une place avec
des pertes proches économique et
pratique hôtel et suites le dauphin
drummondville centre du québec
[Musique]
action illimitée frissons illimité
liberté illimitée
l'événement jeep sans limite est de
retour obtenez le jeep grand cherokee
levé us le plus primé de tous les temps
ou le jeep wrangler levé us de l'année
2019 selon mourad ou le jeep cherokee
levé us le plus compétent de sa
catégorie
découvrez toute la gamme pendant
l'événement jeep sans limite et obtenir
jusqu'à 15 % de rabais sur le pdsf soit
jusqu'à 9600 12 $ au rabais
cette année mode clamato fête ses 50 ans
tout comme les césar
[Musique]
depuis 1969 personne ne connaît les
césars aussi bien que nous et personne
n'aime ça autant que vous
alors pour vous remercier et pour
célébrer nos 50 ans vous partageons 50
de nos meilleurs césar mode clamato 50
ans de césar inspirant inspirez vous dès
maintenant au mode clamato point ca pour
notre congrès on se donne rendez-vous
entre montréal et québec où québec et
montréal comme vous voulez as tu vu les
champs la bouffe une broche économique
pratique c'est ça le peps à l'hôtel et
suites le dauphin de drummondville
centre du québec
[Musique]
cette exposition sur les bancs aux on
pourrait facilement retrouver le siège
je suis assis en ce moment en fait ces
deux sièges sont occupés par les mêmes
détenteurs d'abonnements de saison
depuis 30 ans voici une belle histoire
d'amour entre un couple et l'équipe des
broncos tel que raconté par mon collègue
vidéo journalistes annan mohammad top à
la partie de hockey parce que j'aime le
rock et c'est plutôt depuis qu'on est
avant mort que on est beaucoup plus avec
les bras les banques
on est venu ici en bottes en 1991
chaque brad et moi c'est hélène je suis
né à saint-brieuc
il est vu travailler chez un de nos
voisins
alors cette année ses 65 oui encore
le temps vous manque et les parties
portent à l'hôpital mais quand on est et
je dire quand on est né à saint-brieuc
les chemins n'était pas beau et long
pour souvent c'était on avait de l'année
juste beaucoup de niches
menait toujours deux trois autres
ensembles aux yeux de beaucoup de bons
qu'ils suivaient leurs prix 1
je t'ai pas le seul et bien aimé nord
c'est quelqu'un qui nous a téléphoné
puis ils nous ont demandé si on l'avait
entendu kb eu un accident près de tous
des erreurs
plus et l autobus
des banques ont ce qu'ils allaient jouer
année pour une
[Musique]
incorrigible
cela avait du monde qui seront peut-être
trop bien quand ils ont commencé à crier
des parties c'était quelque chose au se
ruinent les appelait 2d dur quand ça
arrive comme ça
[Musique]
et l'argent amassé par la campagne aux
familles servira entre autres à aider
les survivants à se reconstruire une vie
voici quelques-unes des grandes étapes
qu'ils ont franchi au cours de la
dernière année
au cours de la dernière année et
survivant de la tragédie ont fait preuve
d'une force dignes de l'expression qui
leur a été consacrée en bodchon saison
tous ces culs le même accident
chacun doit faire face à des défis bien
différent leur a fallu trois cent trente
trois jours avant que morgan gobeil
puisse quitter l'hôpital
d'autres comme bryant rachid qui doit
s'adapter à une nouvelle réalité
paralysé de la poitrine jusqu'aux pieds
rien a fait appel à des spécialistes
tant au canada qu'à l'étranger pour
retrouver une partie de son autonomie
son retour sur glace il a fait inquiet
sur luge en septembre espère un jour
représenter son pays aux jeux
paralympiques
cet amour du hacker semble aussi avoir
été source de motivation pour plusieurs
un point de repère sur lequel les
survivants ont pu se concentrer
certains se sont appuyés sur leurs
proches pour pouvoir enfin rechaussé
leurs patins
d'autres poursuivent des études ailleurs
au pays et ont intégré les équipes de
leurs universités respectives lors de
son premier match avec les panthers de
l'université de l'île-du-prince-édouard
nick schulman ce qui a marqué son
premier but le droit levé au ciel il a
partagé son succès autant avec ses
anciens que ses nouveaux coéquipiers
le retour au jeu le plus remarqué
cependant puis sans doute celui de deux
anciens joueurs au sein d'une équipe
reconstruite des broncos le 12 septembre
brian kammer revient sur la glace de
humboldt pour un début de saison chargé
en émotions seulement un autre des
survivantes avis mais tu retourneras
jouer pour les plans cause le temps de
quelques matches en douze mois ces 13
personnes ont su faire preuve de
résilience et de courage pour reprendre
une vie qui ne sera plus jamais la même
leur chemin vers la guérison d'idf
peut-être mais leur sort demain par
toutefois lié à jamais et survivant
continueront leur parcours avec le
souvenir de leur ancien coéquipier gravé
dans leur coeur
de toute l'équipe merci beaucoup d'avoir
été des nôtres
[Musique]